also breaking tonight Fox News brings
you behind the scenes to look at an
Israeli Naval vessel for a look at that
part of the war with Hamas from the
water also tonight Israeli troops
continue to operate in that Gaza Hotel
I'm sorry Gaza Hospital complex that
they say and US intelligence agrees was
a Hamas staging area and commanding
Control Center and in the north IDF
Fighters took control of an Islamic
Jihad stronghold correspondent Alex
Hogan is in Northern Israel tonight with
the latest good evening
Alex good evening Brett in response to
attacks here in Northern Israel the IDF
says that it is using helicopters and
fighter jets to strike hezbo sites in
Lebanon and looking to the south in Gaza
the IDF says that its forces there are
expanding Israeli Ground Forces comb
through the alifa hospital searching for
what they believe is a Hamas Command
Center more tunnels and more information
on the hospital
hostages we see the presence of Hamas in
all the hospitals the IDF blew up a
warehouse making new weapons and has
taken control of the Gaza
Harbor with its Navy patrolling the
maritime border Israel is also
reinforcing operations on the ground we
are ready we are prepared for any
scenario this is one of the Navy's
missile ships currently being used in
Gaza it's here in hia just today to
refuel and then it will head back to the
battle in Gaza ground forces are sending
specific coordinates to the Navy so
ships just like this can take out those
targets almost 6 weeks into the war the
UN says nearly 800,000 civilians are
living in its
shelters every second of every minute
there's a massacre what humanitarian
ceasefires at the request of us
officials Israel has agreed to allow two
fuel trucks into Gaza each day down from
the roughly 33 trucks worth of fuel Gaza
received every day before the war food
and water are also more difficult to
find in Gaza people are surviving on
just one meal a day if they are
lucky back in Israel loved ones gathered
for the funeral of an Israeli soldier
taken hostage her body was found this
week the family of the other hostage
found dead Thursday says at least the
painful turmoil of wondering is over yes
as there's a slight relief that we
finally know what
happened now a new body has been found
that of a 22-year-old man from Tanzania
who had been in Israel on an internship
studying agriculture the Israeli
government had listed him as one of the
hostages and now tanzania's foreign
Ministry says that conversations are
underway to bring his body home Brett
Alex thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get get it anywhere
else